Mình những chiến công thành tích và chuyển thống vẻ vàng của lực lượng vũ trang của khu bốn trong suốt
tảm y năm qua. Tổn bị thứ tốt lâm nhấn mạnh, trải qua tảm y năm xây dự, chiến đấu, chiến thắng và chuyển thành.
Các thế, lãnh đạo chỉ vì các bộ nhân viên chiến sĩ người đó đậu, lực lượng vũ trang của khu bốn đã phát rui
cao nộ bản lính chỉ tệ người thật con sự Việt Nam đã lập nhiều chiến công thành tích xuất sắc trong
cuộc chiến dải phóng dân tộc cũng như trong sự nghiệp xây dự bảo vệ tuốt, sướng đáng với chuyển thống
của những phần thường cao cuối mà đàng nhấn nước, cun đổi nhân dân chào tạm.
Để quan thành tốt chức năng, giận vũ của đơn vị cấp chiến dịch, chiến lượng của bộ cuu phòng,
chiến đe bàn trọng yếu của đơn nước, tổn bị thứ tốt lâm đề nghỉ của khu bốn tiếp tục quan
chết sâu sắc từ tượng quân sự hủ chi Minh. Đừng lối quân sự quốc phòng của đàng nhất là chiến lực và về tổn
khuốc trong tiền mới và các bộ phá đa đợt đảng vộ cuốn cún bốn, của đa hội đảng vộ cuốn đổi
lần thứ 22, của người thủ qua, chú đồng tốt các vừa ngán nân cao chất lượng sản sản trên đấu,
đoàn kết danh mỏ với cấp ui chính quyền nhân dân các địa phương phát liên sức mạnh tổn hợp
xây dự cùng cố nên cú phòng tàn dân, thị trận cú phòng tàn dân, gắn với thị trận ăn định nhân dân,
xây dựng khu vực phòng thu của vững chắc, thị trụ đầu ngăn chặt đầy lối, làm thích bại
bộ phá của các thị lực thu đệ, dự vững mỗi trường hoa bình, ordn dị, để phát triển kinh tế xa hội trên địa bản
và đất nước theo định nghiến xa hội chúng nghĩa, tổn bị thư tổn lắm nhìn mạnh,
việc tập trung xây dựng lượng vụ chăng con khu bốn cách mạnh chính quy, tình về diện đại,
lấy xây dựng vượng mạnh về chính chi, làm cơ sở nân cao chất lượng tổn hợp và sức mạnh trên đấu,
tập trung đổi mới nân cao chất lượng giáo dục chính chi, hốn liện quân sự theo đủng phương trâm,
hình vướng đã sáng đầy, dân lượng bản lính, ý thật chiến thuật, làm chủ có lại vụ khi trong vị trong viên trế,
nhất là vụ khi mới hiện đại, vụ liện trong mỗi trường tắc chiến các hình thái trên xanh mới,
có dải phát thuộc đầy đổi mới sáng tạo, chuyển đối số, dan với cụ thể hoa tự nhiệm hiệu quả các tiêu chi sẽ dựng quân đổi hiện đại,
gió bộ cuo phòng bán hành, tổn bị thư li为 giù vụ khi trong vị hiện đại đến đâu thì con người vẫn lại yếu tổ quy định,
vì vậy, hiện đại trước hết là chính cám bộ, chính xí y cần nâng cao thư li, chính đồ khả năng ứng dụng phó học,
tổn bị thư yêu cầu, chú trọng làm tốt công tác dân vật, tăng cường củ mối quan hệ bản kết gắn bó cuân dân,
có phần xây dựng cơ sở chính chi để phương vụng mạnh, xây dựng thái chận lòng dân và khuối đại đàn kết phản dân tổ quyến chắc,
làm tốt công tác đối ngoại cuốc phòng, gắn kết chặt chẽ nhận vụ cùng củc phòng anh ấy với phát triển kinh thái xa hội,
thương kiện có hiểu quả các dự án kinh thái cuốc phòng trên địa bán có phần cải thiện,
đơn cao đời sống củ bộ đổi, thương kiện tốt nhận vụ trên đấu trong thời bình,
tham gia phòng chống khóc khổ quả thiên tay, bệnh dây tham hạm huy chường,
có ai đây là nhận vụ quan trọng của lực lượng vụ trang của khô,
tổ mi thường nhận mạnh, phải thương kiện hiểu quả nhận vụ đối ngoại cuốc phòng với nước bản lòng,
mới quynh trăm, giúp bạn là tự giúp mình, có phần vụ đáp mối quan hệ hệ hữu hì bí đại,
đoàn khết đặc biệt, công tác phần dẫn rất hay đàn, nhận nước và cùng đổi hai nước Việt Nam lào,
cũng khu cân làm tốt công tác vận động phát lý truyền thống,
công dính tài năng, sướng dành bộ đổi của hồ thời ki mới,
tập trung xây dựng đổi uc án bộ, chứ khách là cắn bộ chủ trí các cấp,
cắn bộ tham biểu chến dịch có bản lệnh chính trị vững vang,
kinh đầy, tuy biểu về phẩm chất, sắc sảo, nhạc bán, linh hoạch trong năm bắt,
sự lĩnh tình lình và có trình đồ, năng lực tham biểu,
tướng giãn trên khai thực hiện tháng lợi mọi nhường vụ,
với những thành tích, chính công chuyển thống về vang trong số tảm vi năm qua,
tổ mi thứ tốt lắm tình tưởng, giữ sự lãnh đạo của đàn,
nhắn nước, chực tiếp là của nguy trung rân bộ của phòng,
tăng hệ tương lĩnh, xí quan cắn bộ trí vì, nhắn viên, chính xí,
người lo đâu, lực lượng vũ trang của cộ bốn sẽ ngày càng chuyển thành,
tiếp tục phát lý trường thống về vang, nỗ lực phần đấu hành thành xuất sắc mọi nhận vụ được rau,
sướng đáng với nguyện bình sự yêu mến của đàn nhận nước và của nha rân.